[Music]
alright so 62% of the people say no to
this bailout the policies that you are
trying to put forth people are hearing
they're feeling good about everything
you're doing then your Prime Minister
did he--wait he stepped down or his
party lost right no no no a minister
yeah what happened was he overthrew his
own government more of this not
literally but metaphorically yeah what
he did was to say to me in his office
that night once a few hours a couple of
hours after the result came through and
I was celebrating with my wife out on
the street and I walked into the prime
ministerial residence and everybody was
glum why are we glad we won and of
course I knew because it was there was a
process leading up to this and I had a
lot more than just a premonition I knew
who's he was at the end of his tether
and he was about to capitulate but I had
expected that the 62% David would have
revived him and he would have wanted to
honor it
instead he was very much down in the
dumps and he said to me Janice it's time
to surrender he was expecting the guest
when you see he would have been a
solution for him he would have said all
on the basis of what the people are
saying I'm stopping the fight and I said
to him look I tried I spent two three
hours trying to addicted to stiffen his
lip trying to bolster his psychology and
it was it was already or decided with
other people members of the cabinet that
they would do an internal coup they
would turn they know in two years he
asked me to stay on I said to him
there's no way I'm going to sign that
agreement I especially after we brought
our people out on the street and we
energize them and made them give us a
fantastic mandate and I'm going to turn
that mandate its opposite by signing to
this no no I don't think that you know
I'd much rather chop off my arm there
and at that point the I decide I submit
marries my resignation
the next morning here is shafted the
government and there was it was just
like a collective lobotomy my comrades
who up until that moment were saying
we're not going we're going to be
steadfast we're not going to succumb
they also did sort of chanting a new
mantra then you mantra that they saved
the country from bankruptcy from
bankruptcy in other words they meant
from closed banks by accepting the last
five years of extending and pretending
and this is what they're doing to this
day and you can watch them it's like
it's a tragedy
it's an ancient Greek tragedy in the
traditional ancient Greek sense of
watching good people descent one after
the other the steps to help yeah so I
guess when I said your Prime Minister
lost I guess that's what I meant he he
won effectively but he lost and then so
so for you I think what the the amazing
through line is is that one of the
reasons that I wanted to have you on and
so many people had asked me to have you
on is because they wanted me to do more
on left economics but interestingly for
the half hour or so that we've been
talking really what you're saying is
that in a situation like this where
where reality has really crashed
everything that that right economics are
more effective has this changed the way
you generally feel about economics or do
you think that this audience is so
unique but do you remember I am afraid
I'm a confused economist on purpose I
think that the general confusion of
thinking and I'm an eclectic economist
people concentrate on my Marxist but I
keep saying and they don't take the
first adjective seriously that I'm a
libertarian Marxist so my influences are
just as much much higher confirm missus
as as it is Marx and games now that
sounds strange how can you have an
influence from hi mrs. marks and Keynes
yeah I think it's the only way of
understanding capitalism and being
sensible about it each one of us of
those thinkers it has given us very
important tools and go
so marks was the first economist to come
up with a theory of the business cycle
of the boom-and-bust there was not there
was no theory of the boom-and-bust
before that atoms have individual David
Ricardo had the theory of the stagnation
but no theory of cycles and the idea
when we talk about disruptive
technologies that's Marx if you read
even the Communists manifest is the way
that technology disrupts the social
relations of production and creates a
new mode of production
it went from feudalism through the steam
engine destroyed feudal has been brought
in capitalism in my installation
robotics 3d printers and so on will
bring the end of what we know as
capitalism bring in some other mode of
production I don't know what we're going
to call it hopefully it will be a good
world to live in but it would be
something very different right there
would be no no purpose for corporations
anymore because the economies of scale
will have been devastated by technology
so that's what I learned from Marx this
is crucial for me from Marx also the
idea there is no such thing as a natural
economic system it's an evolving thing
that's what Knox Schumpeter got it all
from Marx anyway you read Schumpeter who
is Dorian of the right here himself
admits that even like his politics were
right-wing his economic theory which
would not have existed without Carmack's
when it comes to to Keynes the idea of a
coordination failure where you have a
pile of savings and you know so through
pile of savings in a pile of debts and
the savings are not invested into
productive activities that will generate
the income that will extinguish the
debts this coordination failures Keynes
and nobody else has explained it as well
as Keynes hagit was fantastic and fun
Mises had two things firstly explaining
to us the two nature of the market and
the true utility of the market the
market is not just a little mechanism
for pushing prices to the level of costs
a way of disseminating information when
information is very very complicated to
disseminate for some central process the
Austrian idea the phone misses idea that
when you have
do not overcome the bankruptcy loans and
through taxpayer taxpayer-funded
bailouts this is one that I think it's
essential for all of us to understand so
these are the these are my influences
and one of the great tragedies of the
20th century is the libertarians and the
Marxists ended up with followers that
they did not deserve so for instance you
know you know the story about Marx when
he was old and just before he died there
were these young left-wing people
economists who came to see him with you
know to pay their respect to the great
man and they were telling him that you
know we are Marxists and that we believe
X Y Zed and he was listening to me said
the only thing he said to them was well
if you're Marxists I'm not so poor Marx
did not deserve it was a great time word
yeah didn't deserve Stalin he didn't
deserve in the same way Christ did not
deserve the Spanish Inquisition right
must not deserve the Soviets
similarly the the Liberals and the
Libertarians do not deserve the all
those people who speak on their name
Margaret Thatcher who usurped the notion
of free markets and shrinking the state
in order to build up the state and make
it more centralizing more authoritarian
than ever mmm-hmm so so basically these
labels that we use we need them in a
certain way right like you you've
mentioned a lot of labels here it gives
us a sort of framing of all this but
we're entering a time where none of it
makes sense in a traditional way anymore
is that fair to say look the world is a
very complicated place so we need
different smart sophisticated concepts
in order to make sense of it it was that
was never easy if you were if you and I
were sitting here or not so sky put face
to face in the 1920s late 1920s old
after 1929 what would be having exactly
saying
amount of trouble understanding what was
going on then than we do now and again
we would have to borrow from the great
ideas of great men they were usually men
back then about the workings of that
there's nothing new there what I find
interesting and at the same time
satisfying is that during the worst of
times like the early nineteen thirties
or now there is a possibility for you
and I evil come from different political
parts of the spectrum or parts of the
political spectrum to sit down and find
common ground did you know this this is
a silver lining of a very bad period
yeah I mean and that's very much what
I've been trying to do with this show so
I think it's interesting I think twice
you mentioned that this is a type of
coup d'etat do you really feel that
Greece is under that there's been a coup
I mean I think when people think of a
coup we think of a military invasion
usually but do you feel that that Greece
has autonomy anymore really no we the
good government has less autonomy than
am a small town in the Midwest well less
autonomy in the mayor of a small town
Midwest in your country has more
autonomy that the Greek Prime Minister
president and I have experienced and let
me know excuse examples right the the
state has already legally through acts
of Parliament's forced upon Parliament
at gunpoint the gun was not in real gun
with the banks but he you know I have an
expression when I was growing up when I
was around seven there was a coup d'etat
in Greece a proper quilter right one
you'd recognize a coup d'etat with tanks
on the streets the police broke down
people's doors ducted people and the
tappan in a football stadium or various
prison camps and so on so
so that was a good attack using the
tanks the one I experienced was aquitted
I using the banks and you know the
latter is more subtle and therefore more
sinister because I remember I have vivid
memories of living the dictatorship with
the military out there manning various
junctions in the city centre banning any
concentration of people to do more than
three people burning books they didn't
like it just a fact a fascist
dictatorship right but there was hope
they hope that is now missing do you
know why because you could identify the
authoritarianism all you had to do was
to step out and look at the army you
could look at the you know this is the
secret policemen hiding behind his
newspaper watching over your house you
knew what the animals and you thought
okay well all we have to do is we have
to overpower them and it will be free
now it's more difficult to see where
liberation will come from because you
come out to the stage you don't see
anything but there is fear as we speak
my successor in the Ministry of Finance
was my friend for many years an academic
colleague I can assure you that there is
not one piece of legislation that he can
push through Parliament without the
approval if not without the dictation of
that piece of legislation by a certain
fellow called Thomas Visser we sitting
in Brussels
he's an Austrian nobody has heard of him
but he's effectively the governor of
Greece every single piece of legislation
has to go through Thomas reason and
limit let me talk about for just for a
second about the institutionalization of
the transfer of sovereignty of freedom
when I moved into the ministry the tax
department was part of the Ministry has
always been part of the ministry unlike
in the United States where the IRS is
separate from the Treasury and it's
answerable to Congress the tax
department
part of my ministers house I suppose if
it was any scandal including the time
they are IRS I would have to appear in
Parliament and be answerable for it but
I had no control over it no information
what they did the head of the Greek IRS
was appointed by the creditors and was
only dismissible but the creditors so
you know as you Americans say no
taxation without representation
I had a representation and and and and
responsibilities without any control now
the same thing happens with our banks
the banks have all been bailed out by
the Greek taxpayers with money that the
Greek taxpayers borrowed or were forced
to borrow from the Germans the Slovaks
Italians so the great state retains a
majority holding of all Greek banks and
yet the Greek government has absolutely
no say in the running of the of the
banks do you know why because the troika
the the creditors passed the money on
from the European taxpayers of the Greek
taxpayers to bail out the banks on
condition that the shares would be not
non-voting that the shares that the
Greek state would take any change or not
have and would be deposited with the
so-called
HFS F the Hellenic Greek financial
stability facility some institution that
was created purpose made for this whose
personnel would be appointed by the
creditors so yeah we we pig in crime we
paid for the banks they have no votes
and we don't even hold them same applies
to all Greek public assets can you give
that imagine your nations assets public
assets the roads the beaches the
mountains the national parks your
heritage imagine if that was all put
into a special vehicle and it's five
member board of directors was controlled
by the creditors and they would try to
sell whatever they wanted to do to sell
so that they would take the money as
creditors so it's
it's a state under education
[Music]